c'est quoi toi tes addictions
concrètement
vrai addiction qui qui me dure jusque là
mais qui pour l'instant n'est pas un
problème ou alors je me vois la face
c'est que je ne peux pas monter sur
scène sans boire c'est rien c'est deux
vers mais ces deux verres quoi donc si
j'avais énormément de succès et que
j'avais des concerts tous les soirs
serais-je le colis
non mais c'est c'est terrible les
addictions qui a des déductions ici sur
ce plateau Bernard gourmandise un peu
mais non l'alcool un peu non non non
je buvais un verre à midi un verre le
soir et j'ai totalement arrêté
d'ailleurs c'était mais il fallait
c'était bien ça me dérange pas alors je
l'ai vu cette semaine Elodie Frégé elle
est magnifique elle est en pleine forme
il faut quand même le dire parce que
tout le monde va s'inquiéter etc je
crois qu'elle est consciente d'une
certaine problème que l'on peut
connaître pour gérer le stress il y a un
stress que les gens n'imaginent pas de
faire de la télé de chanter ou être
actrice comme elle est de qualité en
plus elle joue très bien mais elle va
très bien s'en sortir elle avait gagné
la Star Ac c'était en 2003 et elle avait
partagé son gars qui est adorable sauf
que le gain il faut quand même le dire
aux téléspectateurs qui les savent
peut-être pas on te donne pas l'argent
c'était un million ça te donne pas un
million de réalité c'était avant sur
royalty d'un album et il y a pas eu
d'albums et Michel non plus donc elle
doit cet argent là elle
avoir une avance
je pense pas qu'il doit me rembourser là
si c'est des royalties
en fait dans un contexte assez
particulier qu'un podcast qui est mené
par Rose qui est génial la chanteuse
rose et qui s'appelle contradiction donc
en fait elle ne parle que de ça des
addictions des vis voilà ce genre de
choses donc ça a été repris un peu
partout en disant voilà j'ai des visuels
j'ai les médicaments mais c'était
vraiment dans ce contexte particulier où
on ne parle que de ça et on a tous des
addictions on est tous addict à quelque
chose bien sûr que si la nature humaine
est faite d'addiction
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
aussi merci et vous vous êtes pas
divorce
j'avais une vraie addiction j'avais déjà
raconté au jeu au course hippiques
et en fait même maintenant je je me
force à ne pas rejouer parce que je suis
sûr de pouvoir gagner beaucoup et
j'avais gagné énormément et j'ai tout
perdu sur une course donc j'ai arrêté
immédiatement plusieurs milliers d'euros
que j'avais gagné j'ai joué sur une
course de trop le cheval c'est mieux au
galop terminé et du coup j'ai arrêté
mais j'ai une question il faut expliquer
c'était un trotteur un trotteur voilà
on perd tout d'un coup en une seconde
parce que il est bien tout perdre une
seconde
[Rires]
sur le fait que l'Angleterre reste dans
le dans l'Europe et
j'avais le micro j'avais des et j'avais
tout mis sur le Dax à la hausse et en
fait le Dax n'est pas parti à la haute à
la baisse et j'ai une petite alerte dans
la nuit parce que j'avais mis un peu
aussi sur l'ordi comme ils vont rester
là va plonger puisque c'est voilà ça va
bien se passer et je veux dire attention
leur monte ah j'ai dit ça pas mal c'est
passé et à 9h00 de la Bourse tout perdu
en une seconde voilà mais pour faire ça
vous avez quand même un peu d'argent
comment ce genre de trucs
alors vous avez des addictions
un truc je peux pas m'arrêter c'est à
dire que si je suis une cigarette je
vais en fumer 10 je bois un verre genre
12 enfin voilà je suis capable
j'étais un peu comme vous c'est vrai
quand j'aime j'aime j'aime
passionnément je sais pas la demi-mesure
je sais pas un truc que je sais faire
donc
apparemment en fait c'est le plus gros
c'est des choses ce sont les mecs les
mets ah non pas du tout moi j'ai été
j'ai été avec le père de mes enfants
pendant 15 ans on me dit dans
l'oreillette pour que je dis tout aux
spectateurs on me dit vas-y vas-y sur
Sophie allez addict au mec
je suis pas du tout
alors c'est pire que ça on veut me dire
elle est addict au mec Maquet
jamais sorti avec un homme marié ou un
club Maké non mon défaut mon petit vice
on va dire c'est de choisir des hommes
qui sont émotionnellement indisponibles
souvent je tombe toujours sur le même
profil de mec qui veulent pas s'engager
qui va mais je vais passer 15 jours
[Applaudissements]